bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans
savouregarde au sommaire ce soir la
réforme des retraites report de l'âge
légal à 64 voire 65 ans réforme des
régimes spéciaux et Isabelle borne a
confirmé ce matin les grandes lignes de
cette réforme elle sera discutée à
l'Assemblée au printemps mais il y
aura-t-il une majorité pour l'adopter et
si la rue en décidait autrement on en
débat dans un instant notre fil rouge ce
soir sera le journaliste économique
François Lenglet et il publie un livre
passionnant qui nous aide à mieux
comprendre les grands bouleversements
actuels est-ce la fin de la
mondialisation et si c'était une chance
à saisir pour la France vous verrez sa
vision et réellement passionnante enfin
nos affranchis ce soir Stéphanie
Despierre nous racontera le joli cours
réalisé hier soir dans l'hémicycle par
Aurélien Pradier là que tu parlementaire
c'est aussi cette proposition de loi
anti-squat qui a été adoptée aujourd'hui
l'occasion de jeter un coup d'oeil dans
le rétro avec Brandon warrett enfin le
mot du jour avec Mariette d'Harry grand
elle nous parlera silence voilà pour le
sommaire installez-vous confortablement
c'est parti pour savoir
[Musique]
on en parle depuis tellement longtemps
qu'on en avait presque oublié l'échéance
dans deux semaines à peine le
gouvernement présentera donc sa réforme
des retraites et ce matin dans les
colonnes du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France Elizabeth borne en a dévoilé les
grandes lignes et le calendrier alors
pour un débattre j'accueille ce soir
François Lenglet bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste économique à
TF1 vous êtes là pour votre dernier
livre sur l'économie bien sûr on va en
parler tout à l'heure mais on va d'abord
profiter de votre expertise sur cette
thématique des retraites constance le
grip bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes député
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine Antoine
Léo manbon bonsoir vous êtes député la
France insoumise de l'Essonne et puis
Jean-François Mathieu spécialiste des
relations au travail nous rejoindra dans
un instant mais d'abord que dit
exactement Elisabeth dans les colonnes
du Parisien quels sont les enjeux de
cette réforme Stéphane blackowski va
nous aider à y voir plus clair
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Clément bonsoir
madame les députés bonsoir messieurs
alors si j'ai bien compris alors si j'ai
bien compris que ça fait 6 mois
Elisabeth borne est à Matignon et là
elle s'attaque à la réforme majeure du
nouveau quinquennat mais attention
regardez un petit changement c'était ce
matin dans le Parisien on ne parle plus
du plan Macron pour les retraites non
désormais c'est le plan borne est-ce que
ça change vraiment quelque chose au fond
du sujet pas grand chose mais un peu sur
la forme ça suggère que peut-être le
président va se mettre un peu en retrait
même si c'est pas forcément son style
sur ce dossier et donc ce sera Elisa de
belle borne qui sera elle en première
ligne pour mener le combat mais sur le
fond non ça ne change pas grand chose
par exemple le calendrier on le
connaissait il reste inchangé le plan
vous l'avez dit devrait être présenté
aux partenaire sociaux le 15 décembre
juste avant la trappe des confiseurs
donc le moment où la politique tourne au
ralenti en France ça laisse un peu de
répit à la première ministre et là après
on attaque en janvier présentation de ce
projet de loi Conseil des ministres on
essaie de le faire voter avant l'été
parce qu'il est prévu que à l'été 2023
bien la réforme soit mise en oeuvre et
là c'est un autre calendrier qui
commence mais ça le Président nous l'a
déjà expliqué c'était le 26 octobre en
écoute à partir de l'été 2023 on devra
décaler l'âge légal de départ de 4 mois
par an ce qui veut dire que là où nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 62 ans on passera
horizon 2025 à 63 ans à horizon 2028 à
64 ans et à horizon 2031 65 ans donc de
manière progressive alors pour bien
comprendre la Emmanuel Macron parle d'un
départ à 65 ans mais il avait aussi
évoqué 64 ans est-ce que
ce matin non c'est une interview enfin
cette question de l'âge en fait elle
doit être abordée dans le dernier stade
de la concertation qui nous attend
disciplin 15 décembre avec Olivier du
soft et les partenaires sociaux donc
forcément le gouvernement va pas
trancher même s'il a déjà une idée avant
d'avoir consulté les syndicats donc
elles sont tiens à ce que disait déjà le
Président je ne suis octobre on écoute
oui il y a une concertation mais pas
pour ne rien faire et donc moi je suis
65 ans ou 64 ans si en plus des 64 ans
on allonge les trimestres moi j'y suis
tout à fait ouvert bon dans son
interview la première ministre donne
quand même une petite un petit indice de
nous sur la question de l'âge parce
qu'en fait elle rappelle que il y a 15
jours figurez-vous que les sénateurs
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont votaient les
sénateurs regardez nos confrères de
Public Sénat l'affichaient ils ont voté
en fait une proposition de réforme de la
retraite ou là je dépense très fixé à 64
ans donc forcément on pense à une
alliance possible sur ce sujet avec les
républicains malheureusement en ce
moment les républicains et les
imprésidents ils sont injoignables ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire du mal de Macron
et de se renchérir est-ce que ça va
changer peut-être qu'il y aura une
alliance possible alors est-ce que les
autres a quand même fait quelques
annonces dans cette interview vous savez
engagé une réforme contre laquelle 70%
des Français sont opposés c'est toujours
un peu périlleux pour un chef de
gouvernement alors bien sûr elle a des
bons arguments elles avaient de borne
c'est qu'ils devraient avoir de
nouvelles marches budgétaires parce
qu'on est déjà sinon on va pas y arriver
mais ça c'est pas un excellent argument
on dirait quoi on dirait regardez le FMI
nous l'a demandé bah oui c'est vrai le
FMI nous l'a demandé est-ce que c'est
convaincant pour les Français
convaincu je suis pas convaincu
d'ailleurs l'opposition a déjà des
éléments de langage pour contrecarrer
cet argument budgétaire on écoute
jacobelli le meilleur snip sniper du RN
moi je me demande si Madame borne s'est
fait greffer une calculette à la place
du cœur le modèle social des retraites
français c'est un modèle solidaire un
modèle fraternel elle veut en faire un
modèle économiquement performant comment
ça la première ministre n'aurait pas de
cœur moi je ne veux pas le croire donc
elle est un peu obligée ce matin de
montrer que si elle a bon coeur quand
même il y a des éléments dans la
retraite à regarder si pension minimum à
1200 euros ça c'est un élément positif
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler avant
20 ans pourront partir plus tôt
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait oui par exemple
les congés parentaux ça sera quand même
compté pour la pension et la même dit
elle avait dit qu'elle ferait peut-être
un petit effort pour la pénibilité c'est
quand même la preuve qu'elle a bon cœur
non sinon elle dirait pas ça
pas ça comme ça vous bon en tout cas
évidemment on sait bien que Nico pas à
la rentrée la gauche est vend debout le
climat social sera sans doute un peu
agité on va dire le bulletin météo et
déjà Mathilde panos chauffe un peu la
voix dans la sembler on écoute
oui
pourquoi faire une réforme dans personne
ne veut madame la Première ministre vous
voilà prévenu un seul geste et vous nous
trouverez dans la rue dès le lendemain
un seul geste et nous vous ferons battre
en retraite alors je vais je vous laisse
débattre mais rassurez vous si vous
n'avez pas le temps de tout dire c'est
pas grave on aura encore d'autres débats
sur le sujet on n'en doute pas merci
beaucoup Stéphane Da kowski avant
d'aborder les différents points de cette
réforme j'aimerais d'abord qu'on débatte
de la question de savoir si cette
réforme est vraiment nécessaire parce
qu'il y a eu ce rapport du corps le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites et
on a l'impression que chacun il retient
un peu ce qu'il a envie d'en retenir de
ce rapport alors on commence par vous
François l'anglais est-ce que il y a une
urgence particulière selon vous à
réformer le système des retraites
aujourd'hui plutôt que nécessaire je
pense qu'elle est utile c'est là où un
autre enfin en tout cas de salon
d'allonger la dieu de la durée de de
temps de travail en France et
globalement et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
une urgence sur l'équilibre compte du
régime si vous voulez les rapports des
corps se sont succédés ce sont contredis
pourquoi parce que quand vous faites des
projections économiques à 10 20 ou 30
ans vous bougez une seule variable
ainsi au bout de 30 ans ça vous fait des
différences de 5 de 10 de 20 milliards
donc effectivement les hypothèses de
départ conditionnent le résultat dans
ces rapports à long terme il faut s'en
inspirer mais pas forcément avec une
rigueur marmoréenne sur le fond il y a
quelque chose qui est absolument
incontestable c'est que le nombre de
cotisants diminue c'est la pente
démographique alors que le nom de
pensionnés augmente c'est l'effet de
ciseaux qu'on a vu à l'oeuvre dans la
plupart des pays du monde et auxquels la
quasi-totalité des pays du monde ont
répondu par une mesure simple allongée
la durée de cotisation donc voilà pour
l'équilibre financier du régime on sait
pas si c'est dans 5 ans dans 10 ans
qu'il y aura un trou mais on sait que
c'est menacé par la pente démographique
il y a un autre élément dont on ne parle
pas mais qui me paraît au moins aussi
important c'est que aujourd'hui la
quantité de travail produite en France
est insuffisante pour financer un niveau
de redistribution élevé comme comme le
nôtre il s'agit pas de le mettre en
cause ce niveau de redistribution encore
que on pourrait mais c'est pas mon
propos c'est si vous si vous voulez vous
appuyer sur de la reddition sur sur du
prélèvement pour financer la
redistribution faut bien quelque chose à
prélever donc si vous élargissez la base
c'est à dire la quantité de richesse
produites donc le nombre d'heures
travaillées mécaniquement vous assurer
aussi la l'avenir du financier du
système de redistribution de la santé
par exemple parce que quand on travaille
plus longtemps on augmente les
cotisations retraite mais on augmente
aussi les cotisations santé Antoine
léoman qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
François Lenglet je réponds que bon déjà
sur si on vient sur le fond le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites précisément
dit que les résultats ne se rapportent
ne valide pas le bien-fondé des discours
qui mettent en avant l'idée d'une
dynamique non contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite donc effectivement on peut
faire dire ce qu'on veut à ce rapport
mais n'empêche qu'il dit que il y a pas
une dynamique non contrôlée il y a
plusieurs bornes de plus de 10 milliards
d'euros de déficit dans 5 ans elle dit
même elle dit même 12 mais je constate
que dans le même temps ou le
gouvernement nous parle du déséquilibre
du système de retraite ça pose zéro
problème de faire 10 milliards de
cadeaux supplémentaires de suppression
de la la CVAE pour les entreprises il y
a jamais de problème pour leur faire des
cadeaux on en est quand même à 160
milliards d'euros par an de cadeaux aux
entreprises qui correspond à
l'équivalent du déficit de l'État mais
venons sur la caisse des retraites
puisque c'est une caisse séparée on
parle toujours que de la durée du
travail mais il y a plusieurs autres
possibilités il y a par exemple la
question de l'augmentation des salaires
parce que si on augmente les salaires on
augmente aussi le niveau des cotisations
qui financent le système des retraites
et donc on répond à la fois à une
question centrale qui est la question du
moment qui est celle du pouvoir d'achat
par exemple avec l'augmentation du SMIC
et en même temps on répond au
financement des retraites même chose si
on payait les femmes comme les hommes et
bien on pourrait financer davantage
mieux le système de retraite mais c'est
pas non plus la seule chose il y a aussi
la question de la productivité du
travail et d'ailleurs le corps dans son
rapport parle de la productivité du
travail fait des des analyses des
projections sur de nombreuses années
c'est vrai que c'est un peu la limite de
ces rapports de toute façon et quoi
qu'il arrive c'est que c'est des
projections qui sont tellement longtemps
que en réalité on n'est pas capable de
savoir ce qui qui va se passer on a
quand même la certitude que le régime
basculera dans le dans le rouge
précisément et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
c'est c'est une question philosophique
un peu plus large ça va nous écarter un
tout petit peu du sujet mais dans un
monde dans lequel vous avez un
changement climatique qui a des effets
désormais très concrets sur ce qui se
passe dans notre pays par exemple je
vous prends un exemple très concret
détruire des routes d'un seul coup parce
que vous avez des inondations énormes et
bien on est dans un monde politique dans
lequel la décision politique et la
prévisibilité des décisions politiques
et de plus en plus compliquées donc
quand on fait des prévisions je finis
juste sur ça quand on fait des
prévisions sur 25 sur 50 sur sur 70 ans
et bien ça pose ce type de problème je
rappelle juste quand même qu'il existe
un fond qui permet justement de financer
les écarts du système de retraite et se
font il a actuellement 26 milliards
d'euros donc on a un fond qui permet de
de financer quand il y a des problèmes
conscience le grip à court terme le
gouvernement ne cache pas que cette
réforme des retraites elle va servir à
financer d'autres politiques publiques
peut-être une baisse d'impôt pour les
entreprise peut-être la réforme de la
dépendance pardon de vous portez la
contradiction mais pas du tout je crois
que les propos de la première ministre
dans Le Parisien de ce matin sont
extrêmement clairs à cet égard et
Olivier du socle sur ce sujet absolument
à maintes reprises dit clairement que
l'enjeu de la réforme des retraites je
vais revenir sur les considérations de
bon sens que vient de formuler
françois-anglais que l'objet l'enjeu
majeur de cette réforme des retraites
que nous préparons c'est effectivement
de sauver le système moyen terme
effectivement moyen et long terme tant
que le régime est excédentaire moi je
reprends les propos de Jean-René
Cazeneuve leur apportait en général du
budget dans les colonnes du Monde au
mois de septembre dernier c'est une
obligation pour équilibrer notre système
de retraite donc ça on est sur le moyen
et le long terme mais aussi une façon de
trouver des recettes pour financer
d'autres politiques publiques les
cotisations retraites qui vont financer
autre chose que les retraites non on
connaît que ça puisse chauffer c'est pas
comme ça que ça va se passer du tout non
là il s'agit clairement de faire en
sorte que le système de retrait par
répartition auquel nous sommes très
attachés et que le pouvoir des retraités
soit préservés soit garantie c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit dans les grandes lignes
parce que ce sont que des grandes lignes
à ce stade qui ont été annoncées par la
première ministre ce matin dans le
Parisien il y a également l'engagement
de portée les petites retraites à 1200
euros par mois il y a des engagements en
matière de dispositifs carrière longue
des engagements en matière de refonte de
la pénibilité de de refondre un centre
de critères il y a des engagements
également très clairs un engagement très
clair en tout cas en matière de maintien
de l'annulation de de la décote de la
non-agulation de la décote il y a un
centre d'engagement très très clair qui
vont dans le sens de la justice et de la
préservation de ce système de retraite
par répartition auquel nous sommes
attachés et donc le corps laisse quand
même apercevoir qu'il est clairement à
moyen long terme et structurellement
déficitaire et que
les différents rapports et raisonnable
de ce qui s'est passé dans tous les
voisin montre bien que logiquement avec
le bon sens qui les caractérise beaucoup
de nouveaux
expliciter les propos de Cazeneuve je
sais pas du tout son porte-parole mais
c'est comme ça que je les ai compris bon
vous travaillez davantage les Français
travaillent plus longtemps il y a
effectivement l'argent qui va à la
caisse de retraite avec les cotisations
retraite celle-là elles seront affectées
à la retraite et vous avez des
cotisations santé qui elles sont
affectées à la santé puis vous avez
aussi de l'impôt sur le revenu qui lui
sera redistribué et utilisé pour
d'autres personnes
on produit plus de richesse et de valeur
pour ajouter également des nouvelles
dépenses parce que si on fait travailler
les gens plus longtemps jusqu'à 65 ans
et bien on aura aussi plus de chômage
des seniors or c'est déjà un des deux
énormes problèmes de notre pays
actuellement on a un taux de chômage des
seniors qui a 55% pour les 55-64 ans on
veut le faire monter à quoi on veut le
faire monter à 70 on veut continuer bah
si en France le taux d'activité
c'est-à-dire l'inverse du chiffre que
vous pour les 55 64 ans il est de 57% et
si vous prenez les 55 60 c'est bien
davantage et surtout je me permets
d'insister là-dessus sur les 20
dernières années
sur les 20 dernières années c'est
beaucoup mais il se concentre c'est
beaucoup il se concentre pour
l'essentiel dans la dans la partie 60
Jean-François Mathieu parce que c'est
aussi votre domaine mais j'aimerais
terminer
à la retraite plus on augmente le taux
d'employabilité des seniors c'est
d'après Elisabeth borne dans les
colonnes du Parisien de ce matin
mécaniquement c'est l'inverse mais c'est
même un des enjeux centraux je crois que
le gouvernement est le Parlement est en
train d'en prendre la mesure puisqu'on
ne sait pas encore qu'elles vont être
les mesures qui seront prises pour
essayer de permettre l'accès des seniors
à l'emploi car c'est évidemment la
solution d'abord une solution
alternative mais même mais c'était la
question que je voulais vous poser
est-ce qu'on pourrait se passer d'une
réforme des retraites bien sûr en
s'attaquant et en résolvant ce problème
là dedans
bourgeois à la question salariale
évidemment de il y a la question des
allègements de évidemment de des
cotisations auxquelles il a été procédé
depuis pas mal de temps pas toujours
justifié et surtout il y a la question
de l'enfant les seniors soyons clairs
dans les catégories ABC je crois qu'on
doit être à peu près un million de
demandeurs d'emploi à Pôle emploi et
peut-être en catégoriale 800000 en
réalité et le Défenseur des droits est
très clair depuis des années et quand on
fait les comparaisons internationales on
comprend très bien la spécificité
française c'est que soyons clairs les
employeurs ne veulent pas de seniors
depuis des années on a tout fait pour
essayer de les d'augmenter notre taux
d'emploi mais les dernières comparaisons
intérieures la fait monsieur ils ont
pris 20 points il a pris 20 points sur
les 20 dernières années
la question n'est pas du Sud des pays du
Nord
non il faut quand même comprendre que
dans dans
la je vous invite à regarder le dernier
testing mais en ligne sur le site de la
DARES qui n'a pas souhaité faire la
publicité de ce qui se passait quand on
envoie les CV équivalents à 48 entre 48
et 55 ans mais vous avez trois fois
moins de chance c'est ça c'est déjà
considérable c'est juste une question
qu'un employeur dans les temps
actuellement embauchera un salarié de ça
change un peu avec les pénuries de
ressources
et sachez que les gens le savent
d'ailleurs un des enjeux me semble-t-il
de la réforme c'est quand vous la faites
commencer pour les gens qui auront 61
ans cet été oui mais les salariés sont
âgés certains d'entre eux peuvent
craignent de perdre leur emploi on le
voit dans les enquêtes du Medef par
exemple c'est une crainte importante et
il est évident que leur acceptabilité
aussi de la réforme est suspendu à la
crainte de beaucoup de seniors
parce que on a feeling Balard qui nous
attend je suis désolé on va reprendre
après mais Philippe Ballard pour finir
un peu ce tour de ta politique donc
député rassemblement national de l'Oise
bonsoir Monsieur Balard comment est-ce
que vous réagissez aux annonces faites
Paris Elizabeth borne et à cette
perspective d'un report de l'âge légal
de retraite à 64 ou 65 ans
il y a deux aspects il y a l'aspect
politique et puis l'aspect technique si
l'on peut de l'Est paix politique tout
d'abord on est dans un pays en tension
il y a de l'inflation qui va sans doute
exploser il y aura peut-être
malheureusement des plans sociaux
peut-être des coupures d'électricité et
là vous avez un projet de loi qui va
arriver sur la table et qui est un
projet qui est réfuté par refusé par 71%
des français si l'on en croit la plupart
des sondages on a un peu l'impression
que Monsieur Macron et son gouvernement
se promène dans un pays incandescent
avec un bidon d'essence dans une main et
le briquet dans l'autre main alors la
réalité de tout ça c'est tout simplement
qu'il veut répondre aux injonctions de
Bruxelles une nouvelle fois on va se
coucher devant Bruxelles parce que sur
l'autre aspect le fond de quoi s'agit-il
en fait le corps dont vous parliez
j'écoutais votre débat dit dans les
années à venir la tendance c'est que
l'on va rester les retraites vont
représenter très à 14% du PIB et le
déficit sera aux alentours de 9 à 10
milliards d'euros par an c'est à dire
que c'est peut-être pas un demi point de
PIB voilà donc c'est une réforme injuste
inutile qui ne sert strictement à rien
alors il y a les éléments de langage
employés par Madame board ce matin dans
son film pour bien comprendre la
position du RN est-ce que ça veut dire
que il y a pas de problème de
financement des retraites aujourd'hui à
vos yeux il y a pas besoin de réformes
c'est
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
quand on est à 9 milliards de déficits
vous savez Marine Le Pen avait dans son
programme présidentiel et c'est toujours
notre programme des économies qui
étaient chiffrées à plus de 65 milliards
d'euros donc trouver 9 milliards pardon
mais c'est juste une partie de plaisir
et puis entendre le gouvernement la
majorité nous donner des leçons de
bonnes gestion de finances publiques
quand on a laissé 600 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires sur le
quinquennat précédent moi des fois quand
j'entends ça dans l'hémicycle j'ai
l'impression de me faire traiter
d'escrocs par Bernard Madoff si vous
voulez donc faut arrêter c'est c'est le
son d'économie qui n'en sont pas c'est
le son de morale si vous voulez mettre
le pays dans la rue bah vous y prenez
pas autrement juste d'un mot pas de
réforme des régimes spéciaux avec le
rassemblement national non plus
non mais on peut regarder ici ou là s'il
y a pas effectivement des choses à
réformer mais je relisais elle il y a
quelques instants l'interview de Madame
borne on lui pose une question sur les
policiers qui peuvent partir à la
retraite parce qu'ils sont sur le
terrain vous savez quand on a été dans
la bague de nuit pendant des années de
très longues années partir à 57 ans
franchement c'est pas usurpé si on leur
demande de travailler plus moi j'attends
leur réaction comme beaucoup d'autres
métiers merci beaucoup Philippe balade
donc d'avoir répondu en duplex de la
salle des quatre colonnes
d'un mot sur ce climat social qui est
évoqué un climat effectivement
incandescent en France aujourd'hui
Antoine léoman vous je vous ai vu réagir
aussi aux propos de Philippe Balard oui
parce que ça m'amuse parce que dans les
dans les projections qu'il y a il y a
aussi les projections en matière
d'immigration parce que les
l'immigrations peut avoir un rôle aussi
dans la question du financement des
retraites puisque ça fait des
travailleurs en plus et donc du
financement de la retraite en plus et le
corps dans ce dans son rapport dit qu'il
va y avoir une stabilité de
l'immigration ce qui par ailleurs et à
mon avis faut compte tenu du fait qu'il
va y avoir le changement mathématiques
également qui va jouer mais je suis
content de voir que on pourra mettre les
contradictions sur la position du
rassemblement national sur le sujet
puisque s'ils écoutent le corps sur la
partie financement ils doivent aussi
écouter ce qu'ils disent sur la partie
ce qui va se passer mais maintenant je
reviens sur le climat social on a donc
une situation dans laquelle l'énergie et
le gaz vont augmenter de 15 % en janvier
en février puisqu'on nous a parlé d'un
bouclier que la levée progressif du
bouclier en tout cas en fait ne protège
pas puisqu'il y a 15 % d'augmentation
j'invite les gens je je pense que les
gens quand ils vont voir les factures de
gaz et d'électricité déjà ça va
commencer à chauffer un petit peu on a
aussi dans le même temps des
augmentations du prix des des charges
locatives parce que vous avez un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont dans des
HLM et où par effet de conséquence là où
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
s'applique c'est aussi dans les HLM et
donc vous avez une augmentation encore
plus forte du prix qui est fixé qu'on
perd chaque mois dans le loyer et puis
par ailleurs vous avez une augmentation
très forte aussi sur la partie
alimentation donc vous avez une
situation qui est déjà explosive et par
dessus le marché
venir nous rajouter la réforme des
retraites à 65 ans en nous disant il y a
plus d'argent alors même que ils
viennent de faire 10 milliards d'euros
de cadeaux aux entreprises enfin c'est
c'est vraiment se moquer du monde enfin
un dernier point
que la parole tourne un peu donc très
vite
dernier point le gouvernement dans la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur en plus prévu
de mettre des amandes pour celles et
ceux qui bloqueraient des routes des
amendes de 800 à 1600 euros c'est à dire
ce que faisait les gilets jaunes parce
que précisément ils ont bien vu que
c'était efficace comme mode de
contestation de l'action gouvernementale
au gouvernement a préparé l'outil
répressif ça vous inquiète ce climat
social cette réforme effectivement qui
va forcément provoquer des réactions
aujourd'hui clairement il y a un front
uni des syndicats contre le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ou 65 ans il y a ce
climat explosif tout le monde est
d'accord sur le diagnostic comment vous
appréhendez les choses alors je sais pas
s'il faut forcément reprendre des termes
aussi spectaculaires que explosif ou
[Musique]
de la politique depuis pas mal d'années
et croyez moi j'entends ce que les gens
disent et j'entends ce que les collègues
me rapportent de tout les territoires ou
nous sommes élus mais je dois entrer à
la quand même dire deux trois choses
tout d'abord moi je n'ai jamais connu de
projet de réforme des retraites qui
soient populaires il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont que ce soit la
dernière grande réforme qui a été faite
en 2010 que ce soit la réforme toros la
résolve Touraine aucun projet
aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est un moment de vérité
où il faut porter un discours et un
projet de responsabilité de vérité dont
on sait très bien qu'il n'est pas
spontanément populaire et applaudit des
deux mains par le compatriotes mais il
se trouve que gouverner c'est anticipé
c'est faire preuve de courage c'est
affronter à son moment difficile parce
qu'il y a des moments où il faut sauver
quand on a dépensé effectivement
énormément d'argent public pour sauver
les entreprises pendant non mais je
parle de la fille
le débat sur beaucoup de sujets
économiques et fiscaux et bien ça
n'était pas facile parce qu'on savait
très bien que ça allait augmenter la
date et creuser le déficit mais on l'a
fait parce qu'il s'agissait de sauver
nos entreprises a commencé par nos TPE
de protéger le pouvoir d'achat de nos
combattre et on continue à faire avec le
bouclier tarifaire le taux d'inflation
en France
effectivement
en dessous de la moyenne européenne
absolument qu'il faut faire face à des
choix compliqués difficiles que nous
aurons à assumer plus tard la dette
effectivement le déficit creusé et nous
devons retrouver comprendre
détermination à mener à bien cette
réforme juste quand même sauvé ce qui
peut être sauvé dans notre système de
retrait par répartition
des retraités augmenter la quantité de
retraite plus de justice aussi entre les
femmes et les hommes ça fait partie des
pistes de travail ça va être plus
compliqué
on a atteint la limite du foutage de
gueule il s'interroge sur l'intérêt de
participer au prochain cycle de
concertation on a plus envie de
cautionner tout ce cinéma en gros il a
l'impression que tout est décidé tout
est écrit dans la méthode non mais
c'était pas le cas des réformes
précédentes
comme ça il y a donc quand même d'autres
manières de le faire et je voudrais
ajouter autre chose deuxième élément le
temps que vous avez raison d'ajouter qui
a d'autres motifs de conflictualité très
importants qui s'ajoutent bien sûr avec
des questions de pouvoir d'achat et le
dernier point celui-là est sans doute le
plus grave c'est que dans le contexte
actuel je vous rappelle qu'on a mis
entre parenthèses toute la réforme bref
on la retirer en raison du covid mais là
on est dans un contexte qui est
particulièrement difficile des pénuries
sans doute d'énergie etc des tensions
sur les transports sur beaucoup de
secteurs des tensions sur les enfin bref
dans beaucoup de secteurs d'activités et
dans un climat de ce type se permet des
conflits du travail c'est c'est
attention c'est extrêmement
plus du côté spécialiste de l'économie
je pense qu'il y a une question sur le
timing et une question sur la méthode
même si l'inspiration est bonne alors
évidemment
le gouvernement pourrait dire au fond il
y a jamais de bons moments pour faire ça
j'entends cet argument mais quand il y a
pas le bon moment on peut se dire on y
va quand même mais au moins on essaie de
trouver des alliés quand on en a pas à
l'Assemblée qu'on en a pas dans le
paysage syndical le risque c'est que et
je le regretterai ce projet soit tué une
nouvelle fois le dernier était une usine
à gaz très complexe puisque au départ
son inspiration était très différente et
puis il a été infléchi en cours de
parcours pour arriver à une espèce de
monstre hybride qu'on comprenait plus
très bien 49-3 on s'en souvient puis le
covid arrive on interrompre le truc du
coup il y a une espèce de de crispation
sur ce sujet et c'est ça qui me
préoccupe aujourd'hui c'est des alliés
nous on a voulu faire venir des députés
à un député LR ici parce que le
potentiel allié sont les républicains
mais je pense que les alliés les plus
importants c'est les Alliés syndicaux
oui il faut trouver des milliers
alors la CFDT c'est radicalisé hein
manifestement alors
c'est peut-être le gouvernement qui
s'est radicalisé aussi j'aimerais qu'on
aborde la question des régimes spéciaux
il nous reste peu de temps pour le débat
toute toute petite chose l'amour il y a
des réformes des retraites qui sont très
populaires qu'en François Mitterrand a
fait passer la route
je suis désolé c'était dans notre
programme c'était dans notre programme
nous avions prévu nous le financement
associé à cette question
Macron qui a été
rééluia
quand vous dites que vous avez été quand
vous dites que vous avez aidé les
petites et moyennes entreprises c'est
faux l'essentiel de l'argent que vous
avez distribué pour les entreprises et
aller au plus grandes entreprises
on aborde la question des régimes
spéciaux parce que les régimes spéciaux
la réforme des régimes spéciaux fait
partie de cette réforme des retraites
qui intervient on l'a vu dans un climat
social inflammable et ils board veut
s'attaquer un peu à ce qu'il en alors on
fait le point sur les intentions du
Gouvernement avec Maïté Frémont
à la question allez vous supprimer les
régimes spéciaux la première ministre
répond la logique de cette réforme c'est
que les nouveaux recrutés des régimes
spéciaux seront affiliés au régime
d'assurance vieillesse comme tous les
salariés du privé que proposent le
gouvernement la fin progressive des
régimes spéciaux se fera selon la clause
du grand-père pour les anciens ceux
embaucher avec un statut on ne touchera
à rien en revanche pour les nouveaux
entrants ils seront embauchés sous
contrat et non sur statue pour ce futur
conducteur de métro le régime spécial il
y tient les personnes qui qui veulent le
faire disparaître les doigts elle
comprendrait peut-être un peu mieux
pourquoi s'enregistre spécial parce que
c'est difficile
de qualification et en termes d'horaires
et en termes d'investissement mais qui
est vraiment concerné un peu plus de 3%
de la population active cela concerne
les personnes qui travaillent à la RA la
Banque de France ou encore les
électriciens gaziers pour leur syndicats
d'ailleurs réformés ces noms il
promettent de nouveaux blocages en
pleine crise de l'énergie il faut
attendre des mouvements durs dans les
centrales nucléaires dans distribution
dans la distribution du gaz on sera être
présent et on sera défendre notre statut
en France les régimes spéciaux coûtent
chaque année environ 8 milliards d'euros
finances publiques
constance le grip on vient de le voir la
réforme des régimes spéciaux elle va ne
concerner que les nouveaux recrutés de
ces différentes entreprises c'est ce
qu'on appelle la clause du grand-père
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
éviter de mettre le feu aux poux dans
ces secteurs qui sont quand même un peu
stratégiques l'électricité les
transports avec la RATP c'est clairement
quelque chose qui doit être entendu
comme une mesure
raisonnable responsable de sortir
progressive je dirais d'extinction très
progressive très progressive très lente
dans le temps de ces régimes spéciaux on
parle des régimes spéciaux qui sont les
plus coûteux pour l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale pas de
l'intégralité des régions spéciaux il y
a des tout petits régimes spéciaux avec
des spécificités très particulières mais
là on parle des régimes sociaux les plus
coûteux et alors là pour le coup
beaucoup de nos compatriotes attendent
quand même c'est une exigence de justice
que les régimes spéciaux dont ils
comprennent bien qu'ils sont très très
coûteux et extrêmement avantageux soit
progressivement éteint pour que le
régime général très progressivement
s'applique à l'ensemble des salariés
privés comme public Jean-François
par contre ce sont des bastions une
capacité de nuisance évidente en
Île-de-France je vous laisse imaginer
contenu de la situation actuellement des
transports en commun pour d'autres
raisons le fait il suffit de quelques
grévistes pour que la situation devienne
ingérable par conséquent sur des pas
réédité ce qui s'est déjà passé dans une
réforme précédente d'origine spéciaux
qui est que ça a coûté plus cher que si
on ne l'avait pas fait parce que vous
êtes obligé de compenser d'aménager les
carrières les déroulements les
augmentations de salaire etc c'est ce
qu'on avait découvert la dernière fois
donc évidemment on peut calmer la je
dirais la grande sociale de cette
manière c'est pas mais on va pas gagner
d'argent
on verra ce qui se passera quand le
gouvernement s'attaquera au régime
spéciaux des policiers puisque on nous a
dit sans cesse vous n'aimez pas la
police vous n'aimez pas la police cette
fois-ci c'est nous qui seront du côté
des policiers pour défendre les régimes
spéciaux en tout cas sur l'ensemble des
régimes spéciaux ils viennent d'une
histoire une histoire de lutte parce que
rien dans ce pays n'a été conquis
autrement que par la lutte et donc ils
ont une histoire qui est lié à ça juste
d'un mot effectivement ça va être
ingérable mais aussi parce que il est
décidé de faire passer le Pass Navigo à
90 euros je rappelle que au Chili par
exemple la révolution citoyenne a
commencé sur une augmentation du ticket
de métro franchement situation explosive
à la rentrée c'est clair bon on a
compris c'est une réforme c'est la
région Île-de-France et Île-de-France
je rappelle d'un mot le calendrier de
cette réforme dans deux semaines de 15
décembre exactement présentation de la
réforme aux partenaires sociaux début
janvier présentation en conseil des
ministres au le temps débat à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat et une entrée en
vigueur annoncée donc confirmée par
Elizabeth borne avant la fin de l'été
prochain pour cette réforme des
retraites merci à tous les trois d'être
venu débattre sur le plateau de SCP
François l'anglais vous restez avec nous
parce qu'on a plein de questions à vous
poser sur ce monde qui vient et qui est
au cœur de votre livre paru chez plomb
rien ne va mais trois petits points et
tout est dans les points de suspension
justement Marco pommier l'a lu pour nous
si on vous invite François l'anglais
c'est parce que l'économie est dans tous
ses états inflation galopante pénurie au
sein contrôlable de la dette les
mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent sans
oublier la guerre en Ukraine et la crise
climatique bref l'anxiété maximale fait
face à des de coups d'électricité de gaz
qui sont sans précédent
[Musique]
pour ressortir ou faire plein de choses
François Lenglet vous êtes le visage de
l'économie dans les médias BFM TV France
2 et aujourd'hui RTL mais aussi TF1 LCI
où vous dirigez le service économique
certains vous perçoivent comme un
néolibéral convaincu pour nous vous êtes
avant tout un pédagogue et un redoutable
interviewer dans les grandes messes
politiques le traité monsieur morales
président de la Bolivie de corrompue
vous monsieur l'anglais alors petite
amie de Monsieur morales votre dernier
livre François Lenglet a de quoi
surprendre rien ne va mais il y a de
quoi espérer dites-vous et dès 2023
changements géopolitique avec le déclin
du géant américain changement économique
aussi bye bye la mondialisation et le
dogme libéral changement climatique
enfin avec la fin de l'énergie abondante
c'est un nouveau monde qui se prépare
derrière tout ça derrière la crise que
provoque ce changement je pense vraiment
que le monde va se réorganiser de façon
beaucoup plus satisfaisante un monde
meilleur on en rêve tous alors de quoi
faut-il se réjouir François l'anglais de
l'avantage du producteur sur le
consommateur d'abord l'obsession de la
baisse des coûts c'est terminé demain la
question clé sera la disponibilité des
produits face aux risques géopolitique
et aux taxes frontalières les
entreprises relocaliseront leurs
industries une bonne nouvelle pour
l'Europe quant à l'inflation elle sera
durable prévenez-vous mais elle
permettra de réduire la dette et
d'inverser les rapports de force
l'inflation va opérer un profond
bouleversement des rapports de force
entre les jeunes et les aînés le salarié
et l'épargnant le producteur et le
consommateur
une inflation bienvenue à une condition
tout de même que les revenus suivent la
hausse des prix et dans ce grand virage
la France pourrait tirer son épingle du
jeu mais quels sont nos atouts pour
revenir au premier plan à vous la parole
bien résumé un vote libre fait du bien
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
qu'il aide à y voir plus clair dans tous
ses bouleversements actuels vous avez un
peu pris toutes les pièces du puzzle
pour essayer de les remettre dans
l'ordre et de donner un cap une
direction à tout cela et puis aussi
parce que vous vous offrez une vision
optimiste pour la France alors je
reprends la question de Marco pommier
quels sont les atouts de la France à vos
yeux dans ce monde qui vient il faut
déjà dire que mais c'était dit
implicitement dans le sujet qui résumait
le bouquin si vous voulez dans la série
de catastrophes qui nous frappent
en réalité pour un bon nombre d'entre
elles ce sont des conséquences de la
même cause et c'est pas des météores qui
tombent les uns après les autres dans le
jardin c'est plusieurs conséquences de
la même cause qui est une transition
comme l'économie mondiale en connaît
intervalle relativement régulier
transition qui clôt un long cycle
libéral que nous avons connu et qui
s'est exalté à partir de la chute du mur
à la fin des années 80 et qui se termine
aujourd'hui ce monde libéral il n'était
pas tellement favorable à la France
parce que justement notre nature
d'esprit elle est plutôt politique elle
est plutôt on nous voyons plutôt l'état
dominé organiser les choses avec la
politique industrielle avec
éventuellement une forme de colbertisme
c'est-à-dire de protection frontière
c'est pas du tout des idées à la mode
dans ce monde-là et ce monde là il a
plutôt profité à l'Allemagne par exemple
qui en a profité pour se réunifier mais
aussi s'accrocher encore un peu à ce
dogme libéral bien sûr mais parce que
quand on change de logiciel on a
toujours d'abord envie de revenir au
monde d'avant surtout si on a profité
mais je pense que le monde qui vient
justement celui d'après c'est un monde
plus cloisonné dominé par le risque
géopolitique que dans ce monde-là les
pays qui ont une tradition une grande
diplomatie des forces militaires comme
la France comme le Royaume-Uni
sont mieux outillés que les autres
justement pour faire entendre leur voix
pour composer des majorités pour créer
des alliances
disons ils bénéficieront d'un contexte
plus favorable que dans les décennies
qui sont terminées alors vous parlez
dans ce livre de la fin du dogme libéral
on vous a parfois reproché d'être trop
libérale aux yeux de la gauche en tout
cas qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
cette expression fin du dogme libéral
c'est pas la fin du libéralisme on est
d'accord c'est la fin d'une certaine
forme de mondialisation qui était qui a
débuté elle aussi justement à la fin des
années 80 qui a été déclenché par la
chute du mur de Berlin et par l'éruption
de la Chine dans l'économie-monde c'est
ça qui a connecté des centaines de
millions de personnes à l'économie
mondiale et qui a donné le signal de
déclenchement d'une phase où les
entreprises sont partis à l'étranger
planter leurs drapeaux vendre leurs
produits faire fabriquer leurs produits
à des conditions très intéressantes
et pour ça on a un AB les frontières au
plan commercial au plan
déréglementations et deux l'État c'est
retiré de la marge des affaires
économiques donc c'est ça au fond ce que
j'appelle le libéralisme donc on en
revient on revient une forme de
protectionnisme regardez ce qui se passe
avec Biden en ce moment je voulais en
parler alors il y a déjà la Chine qui
elle-même est en train un peu de se
replier sur sa zone à elle et puis il y
a les États-Unis qui ont lancé ce grand
plan de lutte contre l'inflation on en a
beaucoup parlé ces dernières 24 heures
370 milliards de dollars pour
subventionner la transition énergétique
américaine on a vu Emmanuel Macron qui a
essayé de taper du point sur la table
face à Joe byed mais on a un peu
l'impression qu'il est un peu seul au
niveau européen là-dessus c'est vrai
c'est regrettable je pense que si vous
voulez par nature la France est plus
encline a justement retrouvé cet état
d'esprit protectionniste
alors que nos voisins et notamment en
Europe du Nord et en particulier en
Allemagne mais pas seulement en Suède au
Pays-Bas on considère que ce sont des
fausses solutions et qu'il faut
s'exposer au québec International le
problème il est double c'est que un
certain partenaires ne jouent pas le jeu
la Chine par exemple qui subventionne
massivement son industrie de panneaux
solaires
le protectionnisme les Américains n'ont
jamais totalement abandonné bah il
Americana ça existe byo
effectivement vous avez des partenaires
qui subventionnent leurs exportations
donc ne joue pas le jeu et vous en avez
d'autres qui protègent leur marché
intérieur les États-Unis mais dans les
deux cas ces préjudiciable aux
entreprises européennes qui elles au
contraire sont sur un marché qui est
complètement ouvert et où on considère
l'abaissement des frontières comme un
dogme s'il y a dogme il est là il est
toujours présent en Europe il est
toujours présent dans les institutions
européennes la Commission européenne a
du mal à tourner cette page là mais
j'observe que ça change un peu regardez
ce qui s'est passé pendant les vaccins
où on a collégialisé l'approvisionnement
on a organisé la fabrication aux
dimensions du continent on l'a fait de
façon intelligente et et on essaie de le
faire sur l'énergie aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus de difficultés parce que
les intérêts sont plus difficiles à
aligner quoi et et on voit bien que
l'Allemagne n'est pas toujours d'accord
sur le fait qu'on mette un plafond au
prix du gaz alors que la France le
souhaiterait donc c'est ce travail
pénible mais ça va être long oui
finalement si ça aboutit ce sera
peut-être trop tard c'est pour ça que
est-ce que vous êtes pas un peu trop
optimiste finalement écoutez en tout cas
on a rarement vu une telle nécessité de
changer le logiciel de ce point de vue
je pense que tout est aligné pour qu'on
le fasse que l'expérience difficile que
fait l'Allemagne en ce moment
l'Allemagne souffre beaucoup plus de la
crise énergétique que nous hein parce
que justement elle dépendait bien
davantage de la Russie que la France ne
dépend d'elle donc j'observe aussi que
vous avez des déclarations comme celle
du vice chancelier allemand qui sont
assez proches de ce que pense la France
donc c'est possible qu'il y a une
fenêtre ce qui est intéressant dans
votre niveau si c'est votre analyse de
l'inflation vous expliquer que cette
flambée des prix c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise nouvelle pour tout le monde
notamment pour les jeunes et les
salariés
si vous voulez l'inflation bon c'est un
phénomène économique
tous les phénomènes économiques ont des
effets doubles ils sont bons pour
certains et ils sont mauvais pour
d'autres c'est assez rare qu'il y a un
phénomène qui a un effet universel et
par exemple à quelqu'un un jeune qui est
au SMIC aujourd'hui et qui a du mal à
faire ses courses quand il voit les prix
dans dans les rayons du supermarché que
l'inflation c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour lui je pense que ça peut l'être un
moyen terme le problème ça a été
souligné d'ailleurs dans le sujet qui
précédait notre conversation c'est le
vrai sujet politique des périodes
d'inflation ou plutôt des périodes où
l'inflation réapparaît après après la
disparu c'est l'indexation des revenus
c'est ça à quel point les salaires
doivent-ils suivre ce rythme de
l'inflation sans l'alimenter ça ne va
pas tarder on voit déjà que les salaires
augmentent bien davantage qu'auparavant
heureusement mais mais les situations de
pénurie de ressources dans lesquelles
sont bien des marchés du travail font
que les entreprises vont être obligées
de s'adapter elles ont fait déjà dans un
salon de secteurs et ce qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que ce sont
plutôt les non qualifiés qui voient leur
salaire augmenter le plus fortement
qui sont en travail présentiel plutôt
qu'en distancielle ce dont la présence
est nécessaire sur le site de travail
cela c'est le nettoyage c'est l'aide à
domicile c'est conduction la conduite
des transports publics
oui c'est pas encore suffisant oui mais
justement le problème se pose
aujourd'hui non non bien sûr et je pense
qu'il va se poser encore davantage dans
les années qui viennent donc je ne doute
pas que les salaires n'augmentent et
qu'on retrouve une une demande même s'il
est pas automatique comme du temps
d'indexation je termine d'un mot à
partir du moment où les revenus sont à
peu près indexés sur la hausse des prix
quel qu'en soit les modalités
l'inflation permet d'effacer les dettes
c'est pour ça que c'est plus favorable
aux jeunes c'est qu'en général les
jeunes s'endettent justement pour
acheter leur logement notamment et que
quand vous êtes dans une période avec
une hausse des prix réguliers faut pas
qu'elle soit trop forte mais chaque
année la valeur de la dette que vous
avez constituée diminue si les salaires
progressent si les salaires progressent
et ça vaut aussi pour l'État bien sûr
vous placez la sécurité des
approvisionnements au cœur des enjeux de
ce monde qui vient en gros le prix ne
serait plus la question centrale les
producteurs reprennent la main face aux
consommateurs pourtant aujourd'hui on
voit des fabricants de masques français
qui sont obligés de d'arrêter leurs
usines faute de commande alors que ils
avaient subi une pression pour pour
lancer des productions de masse français
vous appuyez sur un exemple aussi cette
usine de puce électronique qui va être
installé en France pour ne pas dépendre
de Taïwan si jamais la Chine devait
mettre la main sur Taïwan mais vous
pensez que des puces françaises qui
coûtent plus cher et qui sont moins
performantes que celles fabriquée en
Asie seront achetés mais on n'aura pas
le choix on aura pas le choix mais si
enfin si Taïwan reste Taïwan
que tu ailles pas très
loin c'est l'Ukraine de la Chine donc un
jour ou l'autre il se passera quelque
chose de désagréable et qui va prendre
un verre toutes les entreprises
occidentales qui travaillent avec la
Chine on risque pas de se retrouver avec
des puces électroniques à l'image des
masques français aujourd'hui écoutez je
ne pense pas parce que
les masques on en a besoin dans les
périodes de de reprise de l'É famille
sinon
c'est même pas décoratif et ça sert pour
le carnaval les puces c'est un bien de
qu'on utilise maintenant dans la plupart
des objets qu'on fabrique donc
que l'Europe s'organise pour créer une
filière d'approvisionnement et ne pas
dépendre de zone qui justement sont très
instables au plan géopolitique ça me
paraît souhaitable si vous voulez ce qui
fait aussi la différence entre la
période qui se termine et celle qui
s'ouvre c'est que le risque géopolitique
s'impose désormais à la vie des affaires
et à l'économie au contraire c'est le
auparavant c'était l'inverse
c'est-à-dire que c'était la logique
économique qui prévalait sur le risque
géopolitique le politique reprend la
main sur l'économie regardez ce qui
s'est passé avec les vaccins c'est
exactement ce qu'on a connu et c'est
tout à fait possible qu'on connaît ça
demain sur l'alimentation on le connaît
aujourd'hui sur l'énergie c'est c'est de
fait l'énergie on va payer plus cher et
malheureusement et c'est dommage que
notre gouvernement ne précise pas les
choses pour la remise en ordre du
programme nucléaire merci beaucoup
François Len je rappelle le titre de
votre livre rien ne va mais trois petits
points et avec ce sous-titre 2023
l'année qui peut nous sauver alors 2023
peut-être 2024 ou 2025 en 2023 bon merci
encore on passe à nos affranchis à
présent avec Stéphanie Despierre on va
voir dans un instant avec elle comment
Aurélien Pradier un peu tordue le bras
de la majorité pour faire adopter sa
proposition de loi Brandon Waret
reviendra sur les squats de logement
dans notre histoire récente alors qu'une
autre loi vient d'être adoptée
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet et puis le
silence ça fait du bruit dans
l'actualité récente et on en parlera
avec Mariette d'Harry grand
on commence par vous Stéphanie bonsoir
bonsoir alors hier c'était ce qu'on
appelle la niche parlementaire des
républicains et comme toutes les niches
désormais c'est un peu la journée des
surprises à l'Assemblée il y avait
quatre textes à l'agenda et la droite a
réussi à faire adopter sa proposition de
loi sur les violences familiales malgré
le véto du gouvernement grâce à une
coalition des oppositions en quelque
sorte alors l'histoire commence avec un
air de déjà-vu un député les
républicains très habiles Aurélien
Pradier un thème plutôt consensuel la
lutte contre les violences conjugales et
une majorité un peu coincée c'est
exactement le même scénario qu'en 2019 à
l'époque Aurélien impradier propose la
généralisation du bracelet électronique
les macronistes s'y pensent aussi mais
le républicain les prend de cours ils
sont furieux mais ils sont piégés et ils
finissent par voter la proposition loi
de leur adversaire par peur d’apparaître
comme ceux qui freinent la lutte contre
les féminicides alors retour en 2022 et
même scénario ou presque cette fois
Aurélien Pradier propose de créer un
pôle judiciaire spécialisé pour les
violences conjugales sur le modèle de le
sujet est déjà sur la table du
gouvernement comme la dernière fois
puisque le président de la République en
personne a promis une réforme mais avant
de toucher à la loi l'exécutive veut
attendre les conclusions d'une mission
parlementaire prévue en mars mais avec
sa proposition de loi Aurélien Pradier
écouter mais la pression
attendre en 2019 146 femmes ont été
assassinées par leur conjoint attendre
en 2020 centre de femmes attendre depuis
le début de l'année 2022 102 femmes ont
été assassinées par leur conjoint nous
avons 18 ans de retard sur l'Espagne 18
ans et plusieurs centaines de femmes
mortes qu'il faille étudier et tourner
encore autour du pot est absolument fou
alors c'est ce propos ont un peu agacé
le ministre de la Justice qui a dénoncé
un texte inapplicable en France mal
ficelé écrit sans concertation avec les
juges même les socialistes et les
insoumis estiment que le texte est un
peu incomplet
alors les débats n'avancent pas le
gouvernement il est députés du camp
présidentiel sont très bavards c'est ça
oui c'est très long Éric Dupond-Moretti
ministre de la Justice était très bavard
hier soir et le multiplie les prises de
parole qui tasser souvent bref il joue
la montre parce que je vous le rappelle
à minuit pile le débat s'arrête même si
l'examen du texte n'est pas terminé
c'est la règle pour ces niches
parlementaires et puis soudain à 23h25
suspension de séance c'est coup de
théâtre les insoumis proposent un accord
aux républicains tous les groupes
d'opposition absolument tous RN comprit
se mettre d'accord pour retirer tous
leurs amendements une coalition
politiquement baroque et surprenante de
la vue même des insoumis c'est un
symbole fort parce que le gouvernement
pensait qu'avec les manœuvres dilatoires
qu'il était en train de mettre en oeuvre
on n'arriverait pas à avoir l'examen du
texte final et finalement nous avons
fait l'ensemble des groupes une
démonstration au gouvernement qui est
que l'Assemblée nationale est souveraine
il faut bien voir que c'était difficile
pour les insoumis de faire cette
proposition parce que sur notre propre
parlementaires nous avions eu de
l'obstruction y compris de la part du
groupe les républicains et alors ça
marche Stéphanie et oui ça marche parce
que cette union ça crée mais tout d'un
coup un grand accélérateur au débat et
ça permet d'arriver aux votes finales
alors tous ces jouets à 10 secondes près
23h56 l'article 1 est voté l'article 2 à
23h59 et à 23h59 et 50 secondes soit 10
secondes avant les 12 coups de minuit la
présidente de séance annonce que la
proposition de loi est adoptée 41 voix
pour 40 contre le camp présidentiel est
battu sur le fil et dénonce un coup
politique très personnel d'Aurélien
Pradier pourquoi s'empresser à légiférer
pour finalement avoir quelque chose de
pas forcément construit et surtout
opérationnel pour lutter contre les
violences intrafamiliales c'est
simplement ça qui a été rappelé hier
mais visiblement Aurélien Pradier à son
agenda c'est l'agenda d'un homme d'un
homme politique décidé à s'imposer sur
une primaire interne et c'est absolument
pas l'agenda des et des enfants victimes
de violences intrafamiliales alors à
trois jours des élections internes aux
républicain c'est indéniablement un joli
trophée pour Aurélien Pradier qui est
candidat à la présidence du parti sur
une ligne sociale même si compte tenu du
déroulé de la séance hier soir sa
proposition loi sera certainement
retouchée dans les mois à venir avec la
navette parlementaire merci beaucoup
Stéphanie d'amour François à l'anglais
comment regarde comment l'éditorialiste
économique regarde ce chaudron qui est
devenu l'assemblée un peu dans cette
nouvelle législature perplexité
étonnement déception
quand on voit la débat peut aussi
nourrir l'intérêt ramener les choses
[Musique]
non me semble-t-il alors c'est un cas de
figure très étonnant parce que c'est une
élection parfaitement démocratique et au
fond la présentation des différents
partis à peu près conformes au premier
tour de la présidentielle donc on se dit
c'était la chance pour une fois nous qui
nous plaignons toujours d'avoir des
institutions qui ne sont pas
représentatives le problème c'est que
des institutions ils ont deux fonctions
elles sont là pour représenter mais
aussi pour gouverner et de ce point de
vue
l'observateur que je suis est un peu
inquiet c'est à VOUS Brandon bonsoir
alors le mot squat a reçugi dans les
dans les débats on en a beaucoup parlé
ces derniers jours à l'Assemblée avec ce
texte de loi qui a été adopté
aujourd'hui en première lecture à
l'Assemblée on va revenir avec vous sur
ces grandes affaires de squat qui ont
fait la une de l'actualité oui la
première grande affaire de squat remonte
à la veille de l'hiver 1994 en plein
cœur du très chic quartier de
Saint-Germain-des-Prés le 7 rue du
Dragon c'est la une de l'actualité 130
squatteurs des sans-abris et des mal
logés réquisitionnent un immeuble
inoccupé cette opération coup de poing
très médiatique et mené par l'abbé
Pierre qui compte bien se faire entendre
une nouvelle fois
je ne quitterai pas les lieux
sans qu'on vient forcer en me traînant
dans une voiture nous n'accepterons pas
que l'on considère comme des coupables
ce qui dans la nécessité d'éviter la
maladie est peut-être la mort à des
bébés à des petits-enfants
occupent des locaux vacances il y a
qu'une solution
elle n'est que provisoire mais immédiate
un message très fort et le soir même
l'abbé Pierre est reçu par le Premier
ministre à Matignon on le voit sur ces
images un entretien d'une vingtaine de
minutes qui lui assure que les familles
ne sont pas délogées par la police un
second cadeau de Noël lui est offert par
le maire de Paris Jacques Chirac qui
demande au gouvernement de faire
appliquer la fameuse loi de réquisition
une sortie stratégique à 5 mois de
l'élection présidentielle
le fait qu'il y ait des logements libres
nombreux et profondément choquant je
dirais c'est provoquant nous allons
réquisitionner ces logements et les
mettre à la disposition grâce à une
concertation avec les principaux acteurs
sociaux des sans domicile fixe des gens
qui en ont besoin alors 12 ans plus tard
c'est un squat inédit qui va faire la
une de l'actualité oui 2006 après trois
ans d'occupation illégales le ministre
de l'Intérieur Nicolas Sarkozy dans un
contexte forcément pré électoral ordonne
l'évacuation du plus grand squat de
France ça Cachon dans le Val-de-Marne où
mille personnes sans papiers avaient
pris possession d'un bâtiment vétust
appartenant au CROUS et regardez ces
images assez spectaculaires de cette
opération d'évacuation 500 CRS
investissent les lieux dès 9h du matin
les squatteurs sont expulsés manu
military des événements forcément qui
inciteront de nombreux artistes à
apporter leur soutien aux expulsés
notamment le comique préféré des
français de l'époque Jamel Debbouze
pour l'image de la France c'est pas
terrible le dirigeant et la classe
politique doivent avoir plus de
compassion pour ces gens voilà je suis
juste je suis juste
indigné quoi je trouve ça intolérable
d'être intelligent comme ça bon les
frères bon courage ma chérie
et l'engagement des personnalités
est-elle que les stars de l'équipe de
France de football Liliane et Patrick
Vieira iront même jusqu'à inviter 70
expulsés de cachant assisté au match de
hommage de Football France - Italie au
Stade de France et dans un contexte
d'élection présidentielle tout est bon
pour faire entendre sa voix oui quatre
mois plus tard en janvier 2007 un
nouveau squat fait la une des journaux
plusieurs associations qui luttent
contre le mal logement investissent un
immeuble appartenant à une banque
environ 80 personnes s'installe des
étudiants des mal logés des sans-papiers
et aussi également des politiques vous
allez voir un jeune de 26 ans il est
déjà perçu d'ailleurs sur un plan il est
cofondateur du voilà il est là
jeudi noir c'est Julien Bayou futur
député parce que ce cet immeuble sert
aussi de tribune politique à quelques
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
ils vont créer notamment un
symboliquement le ministère de la crise
du logement résultat 4 ans de squats et
de politique avant que le propriétaire
transformait lieu en logements sociaux
merci Brandon d'un mot François
hollandais je voyais réagir à Jacques
Chirac sur cette réquisition des oui
parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une arme qu'on aurait imaginé
plutôt dans les mains de la gauche et
que Chirac dont Chirac se saisit de
façon probablement très opportuniste
pour ne pas dire opportuniste
Mariette d'arrêt grand c'est à vous vous
êtes c'est mieux là je vous rappelle
fondatrice de l'Observatoire des mots et
vous allez choisir aujourd'hui le mot
silence qui a été prononcé à plusieurs
reprises dans dans l'actualité de ces
derniers jours en Chine au Qatar chez
nous aussi avec la tribune des soignants
qui reprochaient au président Macron
sont silence assourdissants alors que
dit le silence Mariette bah écoutez
Clément je crois justement que c'est un
silence c'est un effet très éloquent et
ce qui m'a intéressé c'est qu'il revient
à son sens original parce qu'en fait
faire silence c'est l'expression
médiévale première qu'on a en langue
française c'est faire quelque chose
c'est plus que ce terre pour se taire ne
pas faire de bruit on avait un autre
verbe on atteint taquerait un qui ne
donnera tacite tes œufs et tout ça alors
que si les rêves faire silence
vous faites arrêter son activité
habituelle donc effectivement ça fait
moins de bruit et du coup le silence
venait comme ça mais le premier la
première intention c'était de sortir de
son activité habituelle pour faire un
geste inhabituel et c'est ce que j'ai
pensé quand j'ai vu les étudiants
chinois qui descendaient dans la rue
avec leur feuille blanche pour protester
contre le régime il sortait du
confinement et il faisait un geste là
totalement silencieux mais complètement
bruyant si on veut et puis on a vu un
autre acte de silence du côté des
sportifs oui les sportifs ce sont les
champions de ce langage visuel sans mot
et lorsque les les joueurs de football
allemand ce sont bâillonnés
symboliquement la bouche c'était
vraiment très fort pour dire quelque
chose puisqu'il protestait contre
l'interdiction par la FIFA de porter le
brassard LGBT donc ce silence il fait du
bruit il faut avoir en tête que il est
toujours d'une certaine façon parlant le
silence on entend autre chose
souvenons-nous même nous dans le premier
confinement il y avait plus les
activités habituelles donc un certain
silence dans la rue même à Paris c'était
installé mais là on a commencé à
réentendre le bruit des oiseaux donc il
faut penser les deux choses en même
temps le silence c'est donc un peu un
besoin de faire une pause dans un dans
un monde très trop bruyant voilà notre
monde en dit beaucoup que beaucoup
d'images circulent mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de son énormément de son de
musique de choses fortes propagandistes
etc donc nous avons besoin humain
anthropologique de par moment faire un
blanc et je crois que c'est vraiment
cette épisode là des silences visuelles
me fait penser que ce code là paradoxal
de silence qui parle va se développer
dans les dans les mois à venir
c'est ça qui a compris notre président
restant silencieux sur certains sujets
on peut faire l'hypothèse Le Mans
justement faire silence vraiment c'est
plus que ce terre c'est plus que ne pas
prendre la parole c'est inventer un
geste
iconique visuel qui va se développer sur
dans l'espace médiatique donc on va voir
merci beaucoup d'un coup mot vous avez
besoin de vous essayez de temps en temps
bien sûr mais l'image qui m'a frappé
encore plus en matière de silence dans
la compétition du football c'était les
Iraniens qui refusaient de chanter leur
rythme alors de fête ça n'était pas du
silence parce qu'on entendait la musique
mais le contraste entre ces bouches
fermées ces regards graves étaient
bouleversant j'ai trouvé je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire que le sport n'est pas
politique après ça merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre Merci à VOUS François
l'anglais je rappelle le titre de votre
livre rien ne va mais 2023 l'année qui
peut nous sauver paru aux éditions plomb
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
vous retrouverez Myriam en Kawa dès
mardi pour un nouveau savouregard d'ici
là portez-vous bien et passez une très
belle soirée sur LCP
[Musique]